first of all i saw the first three
episodes and if i had had more
last night i would have just continued
watching and so that's my best
uh compliment to you on the show is i
kept going um uh so i am curious
is there any chance of savage dragon or
any image comic
characters cameoing in invincible
or is that is there any any chance
uh i mean right now there's not um i
think that that is kind of the magic of
comics in comics i can call up eric
larson and be like are you cool savage
dragon shows up and he's like yeah great
when you start involving massive
corporations like amazon things get to
be a little bit tedious and difficult
and it's not
you know the same kind of easy process
and so it makes it a little bit harder
for us to do something like that
unfortunately the comic ran for i
believe 144 issues
um and it covered a lot of ground uh i'm
curious when you were
talking to amazon about the series did
you say to them hey
i want to do this like i have a
five-year plan or i have a certain
amount of plan how much are they saying
to you you know what's your plan
for multiple seasons i mean the plan is
definitely for multiple seasons
and you know i've worked closely with
simon raziopa the head writer to kind of
map
out like you know the the first season
would cover this chunk the second season
would cover this chunk the third season
would cover this chunk and we have like
kind of a road map for
you know how we'll adapt uh uh certain
chunks of issues and
you know how we'll uh you know take the
big swaths of invincible and craft them
into
uh you know a season that makes sense um
but uh as far as like any discussions of
like oh yeah it's going to be a seven
season show or a five season show or
whatever
we haven't had those discussions yet so
all i can say is uh you know open up
amazon prime on your laptop and run this
show on a loop
please uh the first season is eight
episodes
uh how did you guys come up with that
number was it ever going to be 10 was it
ever going to be
more i think eight is i think the
preferred
streaming model you know season length
at this point uh
it's something that amazon uh was was
pushing for and it was something that
you know we were
on board for and you know i think i
think the boys are eight seasons that
are eight eight episodes a season
uh uh so i think that's just their
format
the episodes i saw were like 45 minutes
each give or take
um was there ever discussion about doing
it for 30 minutes like how did you guys
come up with the length of each episode
i wanted it to feel like an hour-long
cable drama which you know they roughly
end up
being about 45 to 47 or whatever minutes
uh and so uh that was important to us
because
um you know we wanted this just to feel
different this is an animated series and
most animated series are you know 22
minutes
uh and uh you know we wanted it to to
stand apart
uh you know because of its length and it
also gives
us uh a different kind of format for
storytelling if our episodes were
shorter we wouldn't be able to
uh you know spend a lot of time on the
character development and the drama the
way that we wanted to it would have been
more plot driven
and to have the cast that we have we
really want to be able to take the time
to have them
uh you know live in their performances
and and do different things
uh so i think it gives us much more room
for for drama to be in fact
injected into the story uh you have a
ridiculous cast
for this series and i'm just curious if
the way you got them
to do the show was hey do invincible and
i'm also just going to throw out there
you can also be a
a really great zombie in walking dead
like we'll give you a close-up on that
i promise you i've made that offer to no
one
uh uh i don't think walton goggins or
gillian jacobs or st
you know like i don't want to be a
zombie like what are you talking about
um but uh but no i think that uh we
didn't
you know we didn't have a casting
process which you know might be more
common in animation but
we were just calling people up and
saying this role is yours if you would
like it here's what it entails and we
absolutely love you
and uh you know we were able to bring
people on board in that way
uh linda lamontagne our our casting
director would just bring us list after
list of like
you know this is who we can get for this
role and this is we can get for this
role and i didn't believe any of it
and i'd be like yeah sure like uh okay
let's see if jk simmons is interested
and then they'd be like yeah he's on
board
okay go for sandra oh let's see what
happens she's on board like it was crazy
yeah it's ridiculous actually it's
really it's
it's crazy are there any easter eggs
that people should be looking out for in
the first eight episodes
uh yeah absolutely i mean there's a lot
of callbacks to
little moments that happened in the
comics there's a lot of easter eggs from
the comics that get adapted into the
show
uh there's a lot of different you know
little things that you might not be
expecting that'll crop up here and there
so yeah
we've we've had a lot of fun with you
know different little easter eggs that
we've we've peppered in
the show is what i would call violent um
and i'm just curious
if amazon gave you any feedback or any
notes or after the boys are they sort of
like whatever
i think that's an accurate uh assessment
they're very much like
look have your fun whatever uh but no we
i i thought for sure that
i was waiting at any moment to get
tapped on the shoulder and be like yeah
you're you're going a little too far you
you can't do this
and it never came if anything we got
nothing but encouragement from them
which is really reassuring i think that
they recognize that
especially you know with the boys is a
good example uh the violence serves a
purpose it's an absolutely essential
element to the storytelling that we're
doing
uh you know invincible wouldn't be
invincible if if we weren't dealing with
those like
gut-wrenching ramifications of what
happens from the violence in the show
and if we weren't showing it it wouldn't
have the right kind of impact
uh and so i think uh to do it without it
you know you'd be doing a disservice to
the story
and so yeah we really went for it and
amazon was supporting us every step of
the way
i guess what i'm curious about to say
this is a hit hopefully it's going to be
a huge hit
but say amazon says um yeah we want a
green light season two and season three
like
right now uh how long is what is the
production timeline
like behind the scenes in terms of you
know getting a second season
made yeah i think the production
timeline is uh
you know it's somewhat daunting i think
that we uh
we spent a number of years uh developing
and working on this season
uh you know as we uh you know hopefully
move into season two and beyond
uh you know things will tighten there's
definitely a lot less designing and
different things that have to happen to
to move into our second season
and it's entirely possible that there's
already a little bit of work that's
already been done on the second season
so i think we're in a good place
uh uh you know to be to be moving
forward uh
or this show to end up being successful
i have no doubt
that you are working on season two right
now even if you have not been able to
talk about it
100 you're getting more than the first
season
um talk a little bit about how you guys
design or came up with the look of the
show
and how you decided on the way the
animation like the animation company you
wanted to work with
yeah i think uh maven our our overseas
studio has done a lot of the
dc animated films uh they're just an
absolutely great studio to work with
uh as far as the look and feel of this
show
we knew we were working with maven and
so we wanted to try and make sure that
they didn't look you know that the show
didn't look
just like another you know dc animated
movie um corey walker the co-creator of
the comic was brought in to be lead
character designer
uh and not only is he someone that's
intimately familiar with invincible and
all the characters
uh but he is also new to animation and
so there's kind of a
uh you know like a new feeling to his
work that hasn't really
existed in any other cartoons and so i
think it helps our show stand apart
uh i think the most important thing for
me visually was that i wanted
the bright uh uh you know
colorful world of the invincible comic
book to be represented in animated form
uh just because when you start with
something that looks very much like a
traditional superhero show
when it starts going in directions that
are very much not traditionally
you know seen in superhero shows uh it's
it's more jarring and more affecting
um you know when you're seeing heads
exploding and it and it looks kind of
like
uh you know batman the animated series
or whatever you're like oh this doesn't
fit i don't understand what's happening
this is this is crazy uh and that's the
kind of uh
like feeling we were going for where uh
when things happen in invincible you
want to feel like they shouldn't be
happening and you're seeing something
that you shouldn't be seeing
and i think that that's you know that
comes from the way that we uh you know
portray the color and
and the brightness of the world uh let's
talk about the next most important thing
of today
um i see the transformers poster behind
you and i just realized that it's there
um do you have a optimus prime
in your house and what optimus prime
version do you have
uh i i don't i can't count the number of
optimus primes i have in this house
if if this were a game show where you
were like you have two minutes
show me how i would i would have a pile
uh
uh filling this screen um you know i
have a boxed original optimus prime from
back in the day
i've got uh multiple masterpiece optimus
primes i have a couple of optimus prime
statues
uh yeah i i there's a wealth of optimus
primes here
i understand uh i can yeah great
question
right because i have one but there's
every time i see a new one i'm sort of
like oh i could get that one
too you know it means it also means a
lot to me getting back into invincible
um you guys were developing or you're
developing a feature film
of the property with seth and evan um
what
how has the animated show possibly
impacted
the feature being made uh when we
entered into the development of the live
action show we knew that the
animation animated form was in
production so it hasn't affected
anything
um you know we know like the animated
series is covering this so the movie
should kind of cover this
um and that's not necessarily story
function but possibly like tone and feel
uh that that should be a little bit
different but uh
but yeah i mean they're they're being
developed in tandem and they're very
aware of of both versions
at the same time and so it's something
that uh you know the differences are
being baked in and we're all aware of
each other as we're in the processes
um do you have a script that everyone is
happy with
or where are do you think it's going to
be filming soon like where are you in
that development process
i mean we're still working on the script
i think uh i guess is the most clear way
to say it i mean we're all very happy
with the script but i think everybody
you know
wants everything to be as great as
possible so you know it's it's a longer
development process but
i think that you know seth and evan are
very busy guys and uh
we're willing to take our time on this
to get it right actually came up with
the reginald
uh bill johnson for the high school i
would probably say that that was corey
um you know that cory walker uh uh
you know we were both huge uh family
matters fans growing up
and so uh uh you know i think i i or or
he suggested reginald johnson as
uh like looking like the principal
looking like reginald johnson and i was
like ah let's name the high school that
i can't remember it's been a long time
but it was it was it might have been
corey
uh it is now time where i switch into
what we call the walking dead stuff
okay i have a few quick questions um
what's the status of tales of the
walking dead
um and do you uh is it gonna be do you
think eight episodes a season or sixteen
episodes
uh i can say it's definitely not gonna
be 16 episodes it'll probably be a
tighter
i mean i know i just don't know i don't
know what not i don't know what i'm
allowed to say
uh but uh uh it'll be a smaller season
um you know it's it's very much underway
uh
uh you know where uh uh i don't know
what i can say
it's been i don't want to get you in
trouble but i want information you know
i don't care look uh uh writer's room's
being built we're working on it who
cares what are they gonna do fire me
yeah i wasn't i wasn't really uh worried
about you losing your gig
um is that one of those things though
that you guys envision as because the
the recent spin-off is two is two
seasons and you
you know right from the beginning it's
two seasons for for tails
do you guys envision something like that
or is it something that could continue
for a long time
uh i don't we're not really talking
about it um
i i don't know i mean we're hopeful that
it'll last past the first season there's
not any kind of cap on what we're doing
we're just trying to make the best
season possible to begin with and see
how things go from there
i think it's a tremendous opportunity to
explore
you know many different aspects of the
walking dead universe
to be able to jump forward and backward
in time and
and also do things that are you know
much different than what we've done in
the walking dead thus far
so uh i think it'll be a really cool
show but uh you know we're we're going
to see how things go
uh the daryl and carol spin-off series
does it finally have a name i think the
rhyming daryl and carol is
is great uh daryl and carol and carol
and daryl and daryl and carol that's
great like
look there's a theme song right there uh
does it need another title
maybe not right so you don't have a
title yet
very astute right um where is that in
the production process do you
uh and another one of those uh do you
envision that as you know the the
walking dead type
season where it's eight and eight uh
have you guys had those conversations
uh i mean those conversations have been
had again i don't know what i'm allowed
to say
all i'll say is that uh you know carol
and daryl are
very much a huge part of the 11th season
of the show and the 11th season of the
show is an expanded season that is you
know much longer than
past seasons of the show have been and
so angela and everybody is hard at work
on that right
now and and uh you know the carol and
daryl spin-off is something that
i think will uh you know ramp up in
production closer to the end of the 11th
season of the show which we are very
much knee-deep in right now
something that i've wondered about is uh
have you guys ever talked about doing
like
a walking dead series in another
language in another part of the globe i
know fear of the walking dead
did a little bit of mexico and stuff but
i'm talking about like the walking dead
spain or the walking dead paris you know
something along those lines where it's
a completely different country and
different language
um yeah uh i will answer that question
by looking silently over my coffee cup
oh it's entirely possible
right so so this could be something
coming
it could be it could be i i don't know i
think i think that could be actually
really cool i think i think it will be
possible maybe we'll see